[Music]
if you undertake a role which is beyond
your powers you both disgrace yourself
in that one and at the same time neglect
the role which you might have filled
with success
epictetus believes that every one of us
has some determinate rules that we're
supposed to fill
and he doesn't say how this is revealed
to us we might think in our own time
about you know when we take aptitude
tests and find out you know what what
seems to suit us well
trying out different professions uh you
know all sorts of things along those
lines that are kind of experimental or
analytic that could be quite helpful
they didn't have all those those tools
or opportunities in epictetus this time
but he thought that that people had some
sort of role that was actually their own
he talks uh earlier in the end caribbean
about being part of a play in which we
we each get our role and we don't get to
choose the role but we choose how we how
we play it
here he talks about the possibility of
taking on a role that isn't well suited
to us but which we might be more
attracted to
so the what he means by role here is
actually pros upon quite literally the
mask that the actors would put on
that is the word that we get person from
it goes into latin as persona
and so you know who are you going to be
who are you presenting yourself as who
are you you understanding yourself to be
what role are you taking on that's the
question here
and we can reject the role that we're
given or which has been assigned to us
however you want to think about it and
if we do that we're either not going to
have any role at all which is rather
tough to do or we're going to have to
take on something else
and we may try to take on roles that
we're not suited for because we would
like to think of ourselves as that kind
of person we'd like to we're attracted
to that that notion people do this quite
often uh in terms of you know wanting to
be say i'd like to be a therapist or i
would like to be a great writer or i
want to be
the successful business person and they
they just keep working at it and doing a
pretty poor job at it sometimes actually
hurting other people in the process as
well as themselves
and it just doesn't come out some people
want to be you know
the the ultimate attractive person and
that's that's where they invest their
time and attention
so we really need to think about
where we fit in what does suit us
because like he points out if you
undertake a role which is beyond your
powers
you will disgrace yourself in that role
you're not going to do a good job so you
know there's certain things that i know
i'm not good at some of them i had to
learn the hard way by trying them out
and finding no no i'm i'm not good at
that if i decide that i want to be a
great musician and lead a band as the
bassist and singer
i can do that if my aim is to have a
garage band in my spare time with a
bunch of other people but if my goal is
to be a professional musician and model
myself after
oh who i don't know algae ward or or
blackie lawless or any of these these
people that i like listening to
i would be terrible at that and i would
be essentially throwing my my time and
effort away and i would suppose my
fellow band mates if they're any good at
a certain point would say we need to get
rid of this guy and it's that way with
many other things as well that's not to
say that we can't test out what we might
be good at
we live in a world with many more
opportunities than
the time that epictetus wrote we have
much more social mobility at least in
certain senses so it's not to say that
we can't go to school for things but but
you know if you don't think that you
really want to be a doctor
don't go pre-med and then medical school
if you don't think that you want to
practice law don't for god's sake don't
go to law school find something else
that would be better suited to what you
want to do because the other part of
this is he says
if you if you undertake a role that's
beyond your abilities not only are you
going to disgrace yourself you're also
going to neglect the role which you
might have filled with success
epictetus thinks that all of us have
some role some place some position
that we can actually fulfill literally
in greek to fill up players
and
we you know it may not be the one that
we would like for ourselves it may not
one may not be one that's you know very
remunerative or opens up a lot of doors
or
says is is really great and and does
shows about
but we are still doing something good if
we fulfill that role you know uh we live
for example i'll use a culinary example
we live in a society and culture now
that elevates the celebrity chef
well not everybody can be a chef
as a matter of fact uh first you gotta
be a cook and you gotta work your way up
through the different stations
and perhaps you're never going to do
that perhaps you stay a line cook your
entire life
if you're a line cook and you actually
do a good job as a line cook
you probably make hundreds of people
happy a day you fill them with
nourishing
well-cooked you know
nicely plated food you brighten that
portion of their day you're an important
person even if you're not the executive
chef likewise i have a great
appreciation for secretaries because my
mother was a secretary for many years i
know that quite often that's that that's
the part of the office where the real
work gets done and so i always make sure
whenever i'm dealing with any sort of
firm or office to get to know the
secretaries because i want to know how
things are actually going to happen in
the place because the work that they do
is quite often more important than the
bits of things that the higher ups are
doing the managers the executives even
though they don't they don't really know
that up upstairs and we could go on and
on and on and on you know in a band i
think the most important person is the
bass player but that's just my my view
on it but i can give you some good
reasons for that the point is
if you if you want to
fulfill your role well that is something
within your power fulfilling another
role well that you're not suited for
that's not something in your power
just as you are careful in walking about
not to step on a nail or to sprain your
ankle so be careful also not to hurt
your governing principle
and if we observe this rule in every
action we shall be more secure in
settling about it
this is a nice analogy that epictetus is
making here in chapter 38 just as you're
careful in walking about not to step on
a nail literally to place yourself on
top of the iron or to sprain your ankle
or your foot
so you need to equally take care
not to damage not to harm your governing
principle the hegemony cone within
yourself and well what is this governing
principle or ruling principle that is
something that uh
for the stoics and for epictetus in
particular encompasses the higher
functions of the human being
the capacity for reasoning what we call
the rational faculty on the one hand uh
hey logistics
and the faculty of choice or moral
purpose the pro-racist those are
actually all
the same thing
just looked at from different sides and
and epictetus calls that the governing
principle because it does rule us if we
use it correctly even if we use it
incorrectly
we end up ruling ourselves but we rule
ourselves poorly which typically means
letting other things decide other things
coming from the outside other people's
views their their desires for us or our
own unruly desires and aversions which
are not properly understood and and
dealt with
so we need to take a lot of care not to
damage our governing principle and this
is something that at first is a little
bit difficult to remind yourself of
so here's an example you uh you know
somebody does something and you find
yourself getting angry and now you're at
the point where you're like i'm going to
tell that person to go you know do
something to themselves
now
you can say to yourself at that point if
you take a little pause governing
principle
you do have a choice here
are you going to make the choice that
that's going to feel good at the moment
but is actually probably going to
you know irritate that person damage the
relationship and most of all damage your
own governing principle because giving
into anger from a stoic perspective is
not going to make anything better
certainly not going to make you better
it's actually going to make you worse
or are you going to
favor your governing principle and
realize that you can't follow through on
that anger impulse and that you probably
should chalk this one up as a loss the
fact that you already got angry
that's tough to do
that's very difficult
in a real concrete situation to do to
bring to mind that so epictetus says if
we observe this rule in every action
we will be more secure in setting about
it that means that at first we have to
remind ourselves and it's going to feel
very artificial
what's at stake here
my governing principle maybe we say to
it you know we say that to ourselves in
a different way my
faculty of choice that's also very
abstract maybe we say something like
being a stoic
improving my life
someday being free and and being happy
maybe those things are what we need to
do or perhaps it's better to place it in
terms of a kind of moral language like
doing what i know is the right thing for
myself not just at this moment but but
you know for my my broader life plan
we have to continually remind ourselves
and what language we use can can vary
you know we can be very pragmatic about
this we use what works but we have to
remind ourselves of this as we get into
difficult situations over and over again
and if we do that
it will gradually become easier
to
recognize when we're at danger of
damaging our governing principle by the
the other thing that we're ready to
choose or to do
but at first it's going to be quite
difficult and only later does it become
easy it's something that we have to
master through repetition
each man's body is a measure for his
property just as the foot is a measure
for his shoe
if then you abide by this principle you
will maintain the proper measure
but if you go beyond it you cannot help
but fall headlong over a precipice as it
were in the end
so also in the case of your shoe if once
you go beyond the foot you get first a
gilded shoe then a purple one then an
embroidered one for once you go beyond
the measure there is no limit
chapter 39 is a rather curious one in
part because epictetus after telling us
so many times in the uncaridian and also
in his discourses that the body is
really something external doesn't matter
quite so much although the use of the
body does matter quite a bit uh and we
should also take care of it
here he's talking explicitly about the
body and how we treat it and he's giving
us some some advice for that what he's
saying is totally consistent with stoic
doctrine as a matter of fact it's not
just the stoics who
say this sort of thing but some of the
other ancient schools of philosophy as
well it's really great advice
each person's body is a measure for
their property so what he's talking
about there is the relation between two
different
externals our bodies which we can't get
away from right when our bodies die from
the stoic perspective that's it we're
dead
our external uh goods in property the
things that we we own the things that we
use the things that we deploy you could
say
um
here it's it's
else meaning um you know it's coming
from the word for possessions but it
could also mean you know all the other
things that we have as well
and
epictetus doesn't say that we don't need
any property the fact that it it's
external doesn't mean that it doesn't
matter what at all
our use of it does and we need some of
it as as uh necessities for for life
right so there is some purpose to it
how much should these external things
matter to us how much should we be
partaking in them how much should we
worry about them that's where the key
question arises so he says the body is a
measure for property just as the foot is
a measure for the shoe this is a great
example right i
love this one uh if you abide by this
principle he says you'll maintain the
proper measure
but
if you go beyond it you cannot help but
fall headlong over a precipice as well
in the end
if we stick to what our body needs
and don't go into the realm of all sorts
of crazy desires
which can't be satisfied and are
continually provoking other desires
and for which in our own time there's an
entire industry out there ready to cater
to you uh available on the internet
as well as you know face to face for for
you know satisfying uh and then and then
you know
reawakening your desires about these
sorts of things if we do that we're
never going to reach an end to it um so
what how does this this foot and shoe
example play out he says okay in the
case of your shoe
if once you go beyond the foot
what the foot needs
then you get a gilded shoe what is a
gilded shoe it's got some gold on it
right now think about footwear
and what people in our own time
put into it you know think about women's
fashion for one thing all the shoes out
there all these you know
crazy designs which are often
uncomfortable
but you know in some way designed to
make things look good
uh and there's a bit of competition
involved as well and then there's like
the whole
aspect of putting a designer label on it
and getting to charge 10 times as much
for it you know the economy of scarcity
or luxury or whatever you want to call
it
men are not immune to that either right
i'll give you a few examples that i
think i can relate to some of which i
can't so much designer footwear never
been into that myself i see people
spending
hundreds of dollars on athletic shoes
and i think to myself wow that person
must really be into athletics because
otherwise that's a total waste of their
money
but why are they buying them because it
makes them feel good in some way they
like people looking at them you know
they're strange colors or you know
slightly off design you know it's this
year's version okay there's all that and
we can laugh about that quite a bit
i'm much more of a uh kind of down homie
sort
and you know i like work boots um you
know when i was in the army and shortly
afterwards i loved wearing combat boots
because they were so versatile for for
many things
but you can pay a lot
for those sorts of things
and men have their own designer brands
that they buy into and they need the
label on it to show everybody that
they've got this sort of thing um
i in general and this may seem a little
bit dated i'm willing to pay anywhere
from forty dollars up to eighty dollars
for a good pair of work boots and you
know they may not last uh forever but
i'm very hard on things i cannot see
paying
much more than that
that's the exam that's the the sort of
equivalent of the gilded shoe
uh
and unless i'm actually planning on
doing outdoors work i don't deserve work
boots
i certainly don't need steel-toed boots
for most of the things that i do when i
used to handle a chainsaw i used to have
steel-toed boots and that was kind of a
good idea but
for the sort of things that i do
day-to-day living in an apartment not
really necessary right
and uh
here following up on epictetus as an
example we first we get a gilded shoe
right so there's gold on it
then a purple one now purple was a
luxury product in ancient greece and
rome it had to be gathered by you know
from these shellfish and so you know
there were actually laws about who could
wear purple and who couldn't so this is
like you know putting things really high
in sort of like you're not just
bedazzling it with rhinestones you're
going to put some diamonds on your shoes
or something like that
and then he says then an embroidered one
now we might think of embroidery as
something kind of low class
these days because we have all sorts of
machines that do it but think about what
it took in ancient times
now do you need all of that for your
little feet to get around
absolutely not you don't need anything
remotely like that you know we can say
the same thing with other clothing um
there probably is a difference between a
five thousand dollar suit and a three
hundred dollar suit and how it wears and
how it looks and stuff like that
probably not worth the five thousand
dollars
and if if other people are looking at
you and saying oh you don't have a five
thousand dollar suit you're not really
important i don't need to listen to you
from a stoic perspective you can you can
exclude those people
um and we can go on and on and on we
could ask not only about clothing
we could ask about the houses that we
live in
how badly do we need air conditioning do
we need air conditioning everywhere
how how much do we need to have all
these luxury products to cater to our
body for our comfort
that's a good live question to ask
ourselves not only in terms of our
society and the places that we go in
every day but also in terms of our own
living quarters
do we need a television in every waiting
room so that people can keep their eyes
up there and watch the daytime
television or would it be better
actually to get rid of the tv
and maybe have a few books
that's not just tailoring to the body
but also to the mind but you get the
idea that
epictetus is talking about here we are
our needs are actually fairly small
they're they're fairly limited
it's very easy to go beyond them and
once we do it's a never-ending process
that we can get sucked into and start to
believe that these desires
or wants are actually needs
and then we're setting ourselves to be
supremely unhappy in how we live our
life in our relationships in the
competitiveness that it requires
and
the only way to get out of that is to go
back to what it is that our body really
needs to use the body as the measure for
the possessions
immediately after they are 14 women are
called ladies by men and so when they
see that they have nothing else but only
to be the bed fellows of men they begin
to beautify themselves and put all their
hopes in that
it is worthwhile for us to take pains
therefore to make them understand that
they are honored for nothing else but
only for appearing modest and
self-respecting
chapter 40 is unfortunately just as
relevant in our own time as it was in
epictetus's time
we have entire industries that center
around telling women
what they ought to wear how they ought
to look placing them in competition with
each other over so many different things
inculcating all these codes we also have
you know feminist philosophy and theory
that sometimes manages to critique that
well although sometimes it gets sucked
into that in interesting ways and it's
not as if men don't have any sort of uh
complicity in this what what he's
talking about here is the the reduction
of women to to sexual objects so he says
once they're 14 and it happens much
earlier now
women are called ladies by men and so
they see this is the message that they
take from that they have nothing else
but to be the bed fellows of men so then
they begin to beautify themselves
to put all their hopes in that this is a
common problem
epictetus is criticizing this he is
saying this is a great loss
this is not how we should be treating
people
this is not the message that we want to
send and this continues on through the
centuries like i said down to our own
time and it's not just men who are doing
it women also send this this message um
and we can say this about many other
things and we'll get to some examples
about how other people
you know and other other groups can be
similarly getting messages like this as
well but let's follow this out so he
says it's worthwhile for us to take
pains
to make them understand that they're
honored for something else for nothing
else according to epictetus but only for
appearing modest and
self-respecting
the greek for that is uh
cosmii
uh idomonet mones so either monets means
something like you know uh having a
sense of shame or
having a sense of self-respect so that's
that's that's a good thing and then um
the the cosmos word that he's using
there means something like a real
attractiveness that has to do with with
order in one's life
so he's saying you know the the
beautification
industry that's out there is giving a
false
sense of beauty one that appeals just to
the sensual desires
and
what we want people to be geared towards
is something better than that both those
who are desiring and those who want to
be the objects of desire now like i said
we can expand this considerably this
doesn't just pertain to women being
objectified as sexual objects we can
talk about how society sends messages to
uh young men
that um on the one hand you only matter
if you're earning you know
coffee's for closers as the you know
great line goes right or that they only
matter if they're being uh super macho
and uh tough and all that and we can go
on and on and on
with different messages that we're
sending people what is the core of this
we're telling people
that they only matter
if they
measure up to certain
desires that we have or desires that
other people have
there's no unconditional value to these
people they only matter insofar as they
fit somebody else's fontasia a fantasy
an imagination the same word that
epictetus uses for appearance there's
very
fruitful considerations come out of this
what he's talking about has to do
explicitly with with feminine sexuality
and with what we nowadays call the male
gaze
but i think that it can be expanded
greatly into many other fields as sort
of a general principle in ways that we
objectify
other people now what is what can we
take from this we can look to see
whether we ourselves have fallen into
that process of objectivization
whether by being objectified and buying
into it and then being unhappy because
you can never actually satisfy what what
you're being told to do or whether we
ourselves have been the objectifiers or
at least the replicators of somebody
else
engaging in the objectifying
all of this is essentially incompatible
with the way of living and thinking and
relating to other people that stoicism
advocates so if we understand this we
end up having a choice and now notice
what epictetus says he doesn't say well
we just withdraw from it all together
instead
we try to take those who are being
objectified and we say no no you
actually do have value not for what
they're telling you you have value you
have value for something else
we could quibble with how epictetus
approaches women i think that we could
probably say he could have done a better
job in saying what they would be valued
for
but you get the message that instead of
saying yes what society tells you or
what these people over here are telling
you you can matter for but you can never
actually satisfy
you matter because you're a human being
you matter because you have a faculty of
choice you matter because you have the
potential for freedom and happiness
[Music]
you